[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport à
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti à pour le sommaire football
dans le championnat de nationale 3
verset continue son sans faute les
versets ils ont emporté sur leur terrain
contre torcy sur le score de 3-0 le
résumé du match dans ce magazine golf
deux semaines avant l'open de france de
golf au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le monde de la
petite balle blanche saint quentinois
organisé sa traditionnelle golf
expérience au service 5 octobre initie
amateurs ont pu voter au blue green de
l'île de loisirs les détails dans ce
magazine pour ce automobile à fabienne
et pascal burg eux avaient lysiens rang
participer à leur troisième gazelle elle
mène rallye au maroc
la compétition est organisée du 3 au 8
novembre dans les dunes nous les
recevrons en sept éditions
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 68
[Musique]
on commence donc par du football et le
championnat de nationale 3 on n'arrête
plus à versailles les joueurs de la cité
royale se sont une nouvelle fois imposé
à domicile face à l'équipe de torcy sur
le score de 3 à 0 un résultat qui leur
permet de prendre le large au classement
le résumé du match des images de grégory
goetz grégory canal et avantages de
romain à respini versailles torcy
c'était l'une des affiches de cette
sixième journée du championnat de
nationale 3 après une première période
équilibrée ponctuée par un triste 0 à 0
les bercer ils sont plus entreprenants
retour des vestiaires et arrive à
trouver la faille dans le dernier quart
d'heure grâce un doublé de benjamin
louvet six fois buteur en six matchs
depuis le début de la saison
versailles parachève sa victoire grâce à
ioane akassou score final à 3 0 toujours
bien commencé commencé fort rarement et
des débuts calmes et on écoute une
vraiment une bonne équipe bien en place
dans l'insulté de patients et
franchement sur la deuxième mi temps à
mettre un petit coup de tripoli pour
accéléré on a eu un petit peu de chance
aussi au percement cher mais ça fait
partie du jeu aussi avec six victoires
en six matches 17 buts marqués 1 seul
but encaissé
versailles réalise un début de saison
presque parfait des résultats qui
permettent aux joueurs de la cité royale
de faire cavalier seul en tête avec déjà
cinq points d'avancé sur le paris fc
l'état d'esprit forcément parce que
pouvoir enchaîner autant de matches en
étant solide en refusant la défaite
c'est que les choses se passent entre
les joueurs l'état d'esprit le fait
d'avoir un objectif commun est de rester
une partition sur le terrain qui nous
permet d'avoir ce résultat prochain
match pour versailles ce dimanche 13
octobre sur le terrain de courcouronnes
en coupe de france
une victoire et une qualification pour
le 6e tour permettrait de bonifier
encore un peu plus ce début de saison
idyllique on continue par du football
mais cette fois ci en régionale 2 trap a
signé ce week-end sa première victoire
de la saison les trappistes promis cette
année sont allés s'imposer sur le score
de 3 0 sur le terrain du causse mottet
vernis une victoire qui leur permet de
remonter au classement et de ne plus
être lanterne rouge et se retrouve à la
10e place sur 12 on écoute l'entraîneur
de l'équipe
ludovic authie nord pour moi c'est top
14 pro fait qu'on avait à coeur de
débuter le mois d'octobre par une
victoire et voilà c'est chose faite
j'espère que ça va lancer bonne
dynamique et et qu'on va pouvoir
enchaîner les bons résultats sur les
autres on n'était pas encore vraiment
une équipe à trappes ya plein de bons
joueurs mais rejeté par une équipe et
hervé était une équipe solidaire
déterminés à gagner du football encore
et toujours avec le championnat de
première division de district ont joué
ce week-end la troisième journée
maurepas s'impose contre bailly noisy
sur le score de 4-1
voisins-le-bretonneux arrache la
victoire 2 à 0 à aubergenville bois
d'arcy domine sartrouville le chesnais
s'incline 3 à 3 2 dans un match
spectaculaire face à houilles enfin
gargenville bas le pec 2 1 le
championnat est dominé par maurepas et
voisins le bretonneux qui compte trois
victoires en trois matches
un résultat à deux baskets à présentera
bhl se ressaisit dans le championnat de
nationale 3 les trappistes se sont
imposés ce samedi soir sur leur terrain
contre lake montivilliers 79 à 70
lors de la 3e journée leur deuxième
victoire de la saison un résultat qui
leur permet d'être dans le top 3 on
écoute la réaction du président du club
jacques michel et on continue par du
basket mais cette fois-ci féminin on
n'arrête plus l'entente le chesnay
versailles dans le championnat de
nationale 2 les yvelinois se sont
imposés sur le terrain de villeneuve
d'ascq ce samedi en fin d'après-midi le
score 72 à 49 une victoire qui permet
aux filles de vinko berdych d'occuper la
deuxième place du classement après trois
journées disputées sur du handball à
présent les féminines de montigny le
bretonneux vue cartonne cette année dans
le championnat de nationale 2 j'ai signé
mon talent signé ce week-end une très
belle victoire à domicile sur leur
terrain contre saint grégoire rennes
métropole
elles ont emporté 26 à 22 toujours
invaincus les saint-quentinoises pointe
à la deuxième place du championnat avec
trois victoires en trois matches
handball masculin plaisir à jouer ce
week-end en nationale 3 les plaisirs
oies ont remporté leur duel contre
romilly ce week-end à l'extérieur le
score est sans appel 31 23 pour les
yvelinois avec cette victoire la
première de la saison plaisir pointe à
la 9e place sur 12 équipes engagées dans
à la poule golf à présent deux semaines
avant l'open de france au golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le monde de
la petite balle blanche saint quentinois
organisé sa traditionnelle golf
expérience samedi à 5 octobre de 14h à
minuit initiés amateurs en plus petit
blue green de l'île de loisirs grégory
canale et marylène et yapi chinois avant
ça y est babet connaît la position
parfaite pour driver avec trois mois
d'essai à son actif elle a décidé de
persévérer et profite d'un bilan
personnalisé proposé lors de cette colf
expérience la posture l'appli sur les
talons donc ça c'est important
et le relâchement des bras tout
l'après-midi le blue green de l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
proposer des animations gratuites pour
s'initier ou se perfectionner à l'art du
golfe à l'aide de plusieurs ateliers des
trois ateliers qui permettent aux
débutants de prendre à un club pour la
première fois en main donc à travers le
petit glas proches ou derrière moi le
practice et une fois qu'ils ont validé
ces ateliers ils peuvent démarrer tout
de suite sur un sur un parcours de trois
trous ou là ils sont accompagnés par un
golfeur
après la ryder cup place à l'open de
france l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines soit de faire une belle
place ou golf et le démocratiser
l'objectif pour saint quentin est très
clair c'est de faire découvrir le golf
pour tous montrés en fait démystifier un
peu l'idée reçue que le golf est pour
une élite qu'il faut vraiment être
j'avais dire professionnels pour faire
du golf que ça coûte très cher une
activité qui s'adresse aussi aux
familles
exceptionnellement les plus petits
pouvaient faire leurs premiers pas sur
les terrains et apprendre les rudiments
de la petite balle blanche va respecter
la règle est le terrain le matériel est
juste jouer mettre la balle dans un trou
quant à babeth l'après-midi a suffi pour
trouver son swing
un dernier mot de golf l'open de france
approche à grands pas le rendez-vous
regroupera du 17 au 20 octobre sur le
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les meilleurs
golfeurs français
on devrait notamment retrouver la
nouvelle pépite du golf français victor
perez vainqueur en écosse a donné lee
doni les links et qui est actuellement
classé soldes 112e mondial on retrouvera
également le vainqueur de l'an dernier
le suédois alex noren si vous voulez
vous rendre sur ce rendez vous il reste
encore quelques places
l'open de france qui est également après
une bonne nouvelle elle tourne européen
va retrouver la date de la date de ce
rendez vous du 2 au 5 juillet en 2020 au
coeur de l'été comme c'était le cas
initialement le rendez vous devrait une
nouvelle fois organisé au gulf aid
devrait être organisée au golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines
on va maintenant parler de sport
automobile fabienne et pascal burg 2v
lysiens vont participer à leur troisième
gazelle enmène rallye au maroc
la compétition est organisée du 3 au 8
novembre dans les dunes un peu sur le
même principe que le rallye des gazelles
nous avons la chance de recevoir ces
deux aventuriers sur ce plateau bonsoir
soir est-ce que tout est prêt à quelques
semaines du départ presque 7 en cours
c'est à dire c'est à dire que à la
maison c'est le capharnaüm on a tout
sorti de matériel qu'il ya plein de
petites choses a monté sur la voiture
encore et pour pouvoir la charge est
derrière qu'enfin il encore du boulot
nous confirmer fabien travers oui et
surtout faut continuer à travailler
entre temps la voiture est elle prête
alors mécaniquement oui mais
intérieurement aménagements pour
l'instant on a plein de branchement à
faire enfin faire des équipements pour
pouvoir installer tous les appareils de
sécurité de suivi on a des choses à
faire du travail
c'est la voiture que vous avez juste
voilà c'est voilà la voiture qu'on
utilise depuis deux ans maintenant on a
changé depuis la première édition
donc c'est une magnifique jeep wrangler
donc on est d'accord c'est pas
exactement celle là ça sera plus non non
non seulement laisse à la maison on y
tient c'est un ami marocain qui nous la
fait et du coup cette voiture vous vous
lavez changé pourquoi ben alors par goût
par on aime bien la marque
c'est une boîte automatique fabien aime
bien roulé en boîte automatique
elle est plus petite donc plus mobile
bon pour nous c'est un problème parce
que on est beaucoup plus chargé quoi ces
petits quoi c'est étriqué mais voilà
deux par le principe du rallye qui est
de faire beaucoup de franchissement
c'est beaucoup plus mobile donc
normalement parce les difficultés un peu
mieux pourquoi repartir pour une
nouvelle édition
vous avez déjà participé quatre fois 1
si je me trompe pas au rallye des
gazelles c'est ça vous avez participé à
trois éditions la troisième ça va être
la troisième année avec pascal cette
édition au total alors en fait si j'ai
fait 4 allée des gazelles et quand le
l'organisateur du rallye aïcha des
gazelles a créé le gaz et les domaines
avec pascal on s'est dit ça c'est pour
nous parce que parce que ça permet ça
permet aux gazelles de pouvoir présenter
le rallye aïcha des gazelles à leur
conjoint quand vous préparez rallye
aïcha des gazelles c'est des années de
ces des mois et des mois de préparation
toute la famille supporte
il a donc on avait l'opportunité de
pouvoir partir ensemble sur les deux
derniers rallyes c'est moi qui conduis
mai
pourquoi partir sur un troisième rallye
parce que parce que cette année on va un
peu innové c'est pascal qui va fêter au
piloter et moi je me lance dans la
navigation aux inquiets vous est
confiante sur la navigation en fait j'en
ai fait un petit peu l'année dernière et
je n'écarte 1 et ça m'a beaucoup plu oui
en fait c'est pour montrer que c'est pas
du tout un rally de vitesse s'il n'y a
pas de gps du tout voilà ça c'est nous
nous étions travail pursuit y voilà
c'est une carte en noir et blanc sur
lequel ils pourront nous point on pose
des points de géodésique et donc on a
rendent à une boussole de visée et puis
on a une règle taux progressent trop
topographiques et voilà ça c'est nos
instruments de travail tout gps tout
appareil électronique sont interdits
donc on n'a même plus loin notre
téléphone qu'on n'a plus rien qu aucune
liaison avec le monde extérieur
c'est ça qui vous plaît aussi qu'est ce
qu'on ressent justement qu'on est dans
la course à ce sentiment de liberté
c'est déjà de par le les espaces et fait
justement gatti vrai aussi à nous mêmes
le faut le faire pour le savoir les
psaumes aulas a requis 10 inscriptions
dit forcément budget comment ça s'est
passé cette année la bérézina c'est
compliqué compliqué oui bon déjà il faut
beaucoup de temps qu'on n'a pas
forcément eu pour pouvoir développer
je pense que bon bah
une période économique peut-être pas
simple ça que il ya quand même
aujourd'hui beaucoup de compétitions à
faire les sociétés sont énormément
sollicités donc c'était compliqué donc
cette année
on à gratter les fonds de tiroir on a
sollicité la famille les amis qui ont
pas donc voilà alors les rôles vont être
définies est ce que vous serez du coup
le pilote du coup sûr cette aventure
comment vous sentez à la base oui on est
parti pour définir mais en même temps
vous pouvez changer à tout à fait
possible voilà fabienne est prédestiné
un petit peu tout ce qui est
franchissement un peu technique à la
dorsale qui elle le fait très bien
donc pourquoi pas qu'il puisse piloter
dans ces moments-là mois la navigation
je dis pas qu'elle a pas besoin d'être
très fine mais voilà je peux gérer
par contre les partis un peu plus rapide
ou dans les dunes un peu plus dynamiques
dans les dunes par exemple ben c'est moi
qui prendrai le volant puisque c'est un
peu plus ma spécialité
est ce que c'est une course difficile je
dirais pour ceux qui alors pour ceux qui
n'ont qu'une connaissance ou pas trop en
pilotage 4,4 sur le pays la dalle est
dans le désert autrement qu en autocar à
un vraiment dans le désert et puis de la
navigation si on cumule tous oui c'est
difficile
maintenant c'est pas surmontable il
suffit de se préparer quand même un
petit peu
fabien escaillas un moment on se dit
stop c'est fini j'arrête
c'était mon dernier rallye des gazelles
à chaque fois que j'arrête ou à chaque
fois qu'on disons que dans sa chacra dit
il ya bien une fois où je me dis mais
enfin qu'est ce que je suis venu faire
là mais on passe outre et c'est toujours
un bonheur toujours renouvelé vous êtes
entraînés quand même malgré votre
expérience pour cette édition
l'entraînement fabienne a travaillé sur
les cartes pour le
pour pouvoir positionner les points qui
vont nous est donnée par l'organisateur
pour avoir de la rapidité dans la pose
parce que bon bain les journées sont
longues et courtes à la fois il faut
passer le moins de temps possible à
mettre le parcours sur la carte
bon après
l'entraînement en terme de paysage moi
je pratique le 4-4 toute l'année
professionnellement parlant donc le bal
manche
voilà notre entraînement c'est
l'expérience qu'ont à qui tous et tout
au long de ces années
m me veil moi je suis j'ai une école de
pilotage automobile
on partait avec une longueur d'avancé
vous hri enfin si j'avais rendu une
longueur dames elle était juste avant me
et déjà résultats justement celui des 8e
et 5e donc plutôt dans le haut du
classement c'est plutôt le haut du
classement rehausser sa mais devant il
ya voilà puis on sait déjà le devant il
ya ce qu'on comme on dit du grain à
moudre un petit peu on a vu qu'avec
quelques équipages affûtés aussi donc
voilà ça manque pas d'intérêt quand on
est un peu plus nombreux et puis en même
temps l'organisateur aussi à vue
on n'a pas le parcours il est secret le
parcours mais on a quelques idées et
finalement j'ai l'impression qu'ils nous
en train de nous mijoter quelque chose
quand et cette année c'est la gagne
forcément on n'aime pas ça porte malheur
ans et oui enfin on fait du mieux qu'on
peut et vraiment c'est l'essentiel
dernière question il ya également des
rencontres dans les écoles aussi vous
avez effectué ces derniers mois c'est
important pour vous et par exemple
visiter l'école élémentaire mozart
jeunes de cm2 en fait là on a voulu
présenter
justement on a voulu présenter notre
projet et faire participer
des enfants à à ce qu'on va vivre pour
leur permettre de rencontrer d'autres
écoles puisqu'en défini en fait ils vont
être en relation avec une école
élémentaire de deir food voilà et donc
que l'on connaît qu'on va mettre en en
communication avec l'école de mozart
pourquoi mozart parce que parce que
c'est le quartier parce que j'y ai fait
mes classes ya quelques années de ça nos
enfants ont fait leurs classes là bas
aussi il ya quelques années de ça aussi
et et puis en fait ça permet
effectivement de de permettre à des
enfants qui qui connaissent pas
forcément le maroc de voir un petit peu
le parcours le voyage et que c'est pas
uniquement le rallye s'est pas
uniquement un rally de vitesse parce
qu'en fait les enfants ils connaissent
bien le dakar
et leur présenter une bonne forme de
rallye merci à tous les deux d'être
passé sur ce plateau vous souhaite bon
courage pour cette aventure de départ
est programmé le 3 novembre prochain
après vérifications techniques
je tiens à le préciser on suivra votre
périple avec attention
en cyclisme sur piste la fédération
française a dévoilé la liste des
coureurs sélectionnés pour les
championnats d'europe sur piste
d'apeldoorn aux pays bas on retrouve
chez les sprinters mathilde de gros chez
les féminines jeu les gars on note la
présence du plaisir ou à michael
d'almeida ligny montrent un ryan et la
halle ou encore le pistard du vc laon
cours saint quentin en yvelines quand à
la fargue le championnat d'europe seront
organisées du 16 au 20 octobre résultats
obligatoire pour postuler à une place en
équipe de france aux jo de tokyo fois on
continue à parler de cyclisme et plus
précisément de bmx freestyle flat
matthias dandois super star de la
discipline idea réseaux sociaux est
venue fin septembre vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines
ce sportif a remporté en 2018 la coupe
du monde générale puissiez en 2019 il a
terminé à deuxième de la world cup world
cup hiroshima nous lui avons posée à
trois questions
[Musique]
mais début d'année j'ai commencé le
bénisse parce que j'étais nul en foot et
elle a un coach qui me criait tout le
temps dessus et du coup ça m'a saoulé
puis j'en ai vu à la télé du bmx aux
jeux titin trop bien le mec qui a
personne qui lui crie dessus et ça a
l'air fort chouette ce qu'ils faisaient
du coup j'ai commencé à faire du bmx
comme ça
[Musique]
mon plus grand kiff dans le bmx est
d'inventer mais figure d'être créatif
que mon vélo sur le prolongement de ma
créativité
[Musique]
les futurs objectif c'est de gagner les
championnats du monde à chengdu en chine
ou en novembre
on s'est retrouvés un gigot une charge
comment dit on prend maintenant la
direction de la piscine à salvador
allende des clayes-sous-bois la plaisir
oise julie peugeot 30 ans a remporté cet
été
le concours de miss sirène france et oui
vous avez bien entendu cette discipline
et lady inédite et originale mélange à
la fois le sport et la beauté objectif
retenir sa respiration avec un costume
de sirène à montage de romain à respini
une sirène dans les eaux yvelinoise
l'appeler oise julie peugeot 30 ans
baigne dans le maire mais digne depuis
un an une discipline insolite qui allie
natation et beauté avec un costume de
femme poisson en élasthanne ces
disciplines requiert une préparation
physique la sportive plonge deux fois
par semaine en piscine
on nous demande des performances en
apnée en général je suis sur 40 secondes
à une minute 15 man records
vous avez
des figures à faire si vous souhaitez en
effet elles sont pas imposés mais en
effet il ya des vernis on doit aussi
également savoir poser sous l'eau on va
dire en mode très statique en complément
julie s'entraîne trois fois par semaine
sur terre dans une salle de sport
sécession lui ont permis de se présenter
au concours miss france de la discipline
une épreuve qu'elle a remporté en
juillet dernier en bretagne face à huit
candidates
je m'attendais pas du tout à gagner pas
du tout j'y étais allé ont plutôt en
mode plutôt défi personnel
voulait vivre aussi une expérience avec
d'autres sirènes parce que c'est pas
tous les jours que l'on peut rencontrer
des sirènes en france donc cet événement
nous a permis de nous regrouper de nous
partager nous pas dire nos connaissances
nos savoir faire un titre que la jeune
sportive à bord firman la piscine
salvador allende des clayes-sous-bois
son lieu d'entraînement depuis plusieurs
mois ici tout le monde est sous le
charme de cette sirène d'un mètre 65
je trouve que c'est une activité
un peu
un peu spécial mais très sympa un peu
magique
un peu comme ça donc dans un premier
temps on va l'accueillir et puis après
on va essayer de faire une activité avec
les gens qui puisse nager avec elle avec
de la musique
julie espère désormais participer à un
concours international de sirène
programmé en egypte en 2020 avec un
objectif en tête ramener une nouvelle
fois les sharp
à la maison on passe maintenant notre
page agenda on commence cet agent d'un
parent de la marche nordique à
versailles ce dimanche un événement
baptisé la nordique versailles est
organisée sur ce sport parc des noues
êtes vous nous en parler nous recevons
sur ce plateau armelle douroux l'une des
organisatrices et coach de marche
nordique bon soir dans ça alors est ce
que vous nous présentez un peu votre
discipline la marche la marche nordique
donc nous avons deux bâtons spécifiques
pour cette activité ses bâtons vont nous
servir à nous propulser donc c'est une
activité de plein air et l' avantage
c'est que ça pousse les gens à sortir de
chez eux c'est une activité très
conviviale est-ce que ce sportif oui
tout à fait les bâtons dans une serre va
nous propulser donc c'est une marche
dynamique et nous allons rendre renforcé
avec ses bâtons les épaules parce qu'on
va pousser davantage donc sur les bâtons
des bêtes les bâtons les plantes
toujours derrière soi donc c'est sportif
ça permet aussi de développer la
respiration le souffle ça permet de
travailler au niveau cardio ce qu'on
peut faire des changements de rythme on
va aussi jouer avec le relief
justement quelle partie du corps ça fait
travailler tout le haut du corps
j'imagine alors tout à fait par rapport
à la marche traditionnelle ou à la
course à pied on va se servir davantage
de la partie supérieure
les membres supérieurs les épaules les
triceps les grands dorsaux est-ce que
c'est déconseillé à certaines personnes
alors c'est déconseillé lorsque l'on a
des cas de tendinite ou de capsule it à
l'épaule notamment parce que il ya cet
effet de pousser et donc dans ces cas là
c'est déconseillé
alors c'est un sport très populaire dans
les pays nordiques notamment en finlande
1 1 habitant sur cinq fait de la marche
nordique pourquoi en france ça prend pas
forcément bien ça commence à prendre et
à se développer de plus en plus et
attend tous la pratique loisir donc les
groupes on va se promener on a le temps
de papoter généralement on apprécie
beaucoup et puis il ya aussi la pratique
sportive est en compétition et à cet
égard la fédération française
d'athlétisme et délégataire depuis 2009
donc c'est elle qui va former des
entraîneurs c'est elle qui va régir les
règles pour les compétitions et
organiser aussi des championnats
lorsque vous êtes combien nous dépassons
la centaine vous avez commencé on a
commencé il ya sept huit ans et nous
sommes aujourd'hui cinq entraîneurs ça
évolue forcément au fur et à mesure des
années ce que vous avez un objectif en
terme de licenciés c'est déjà pas mal là
on atteint le quota maximum un petit peu
parce que en fait il faudrait que l'on
arrive à former davantage d'entraîneur
donc on va revenir sur l'événement est
ce qu'on peut vous en dira un peu plus
comment ça va se dérouler oui alors les
développements de la matinée il ya deux
parcourant ce soir voilà y'a de parcours
on va commencer à 9h30 par l'épreuve de
compétition versailles la nordique royal
avec une marche de 15 km à effectuer en
deux boucles
et puis ensuite on va continuer avec une
ville a viré
visez loisirs donc sans esprit de
compétition tout à fait libre donc une
visée sans chronométrage et sans
classement
et puis à l'issue de la virée de la
fontaine de la virée loisirs il y aura
aussi la possibilité de venir essayer de
faire une initiation et la lune y at-il
de versailles mettra à disposition du
bâton est-ce qu'on peut encore
s'inscrire
ce sera ma delun question oui tout à
fait oui oui on peut s'inscrire jusqu'au
une demi heure avant le départ il ya
possibilité d'aller chercher ci de ça
des s'inscrire la veille chez notre
partenaire ou de s'inscrire encore le
matin même merci à vous dépasser sur ce
plateau la première édition de la
nordique royal c'est ce dimanche 13
octobre à partir de 9h30
un autre rendez vous à noter à dans vos
agendas à plaisir organise sa run and
bike pour cette cinquième édition les
participants vont s'élancer depuis le
parc du château programme des courses
pour les jeunes de 6 ans à 17 ans mais
parcours adultes de 8 et 15 km seront
également organisées le principe
il faudra courir et pédaler avec un vélo
pour deux si vous voulez vous vous
inscrire il reste encore des places
une autre course sera organisée sont
organisées ce week-end la ville
proviennent au programme des courses
adultes enfin une randonnée de 10 km
dans les bois environnants ce dimanche
13 octobre on attend près de 300
sportifs à 9h30 sur la rue du collège
il reste là aussi quelques places et
vous pouvez vous inscrire jusqu'au
samedi au complexe
alain mimoun et on termine par un
rendez-vous équitation un concours
complet international est organisé à
partir de jeudi jusqu'à ce dimanche
solide de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines au programme notamment des
épreuves nationales plusieurs centaines
de cavaliers sont attendus pour cet
événement
si vous êtes intéressé à l'entrée est
libre c'est la fin de cette émission
merci l'avoir suivi très belle soirée
sur tb 68
[Musique]